you
[Music]
hello there there's only two weeks until
Halloween hits the fortnite island but
before that we have today's update which
has the most map changes ever in a
weekly update granted most of that is
very similar hexagonal columns and shiny
stuff but there are still secrets to be
found today we are looking at another
Fallen POI from a crack in the sky the
nothing finally reveals themselves
you're not the one we're looking for and
the Bromance is officially five strong
here is the usual code adamaru begging
thank you very much chapter three season
four week three let's go
the Chrome is spreading in the first
week of the Season while the seven
dallied about the real heroes got to
work no sweat Insurance raised buildings
from the ground moments before they were
taken by the shiny stuff this week that
strategy continues but Chrome has
reached sleepy sound the hexagons are
once again taking over luckily no sweat
has saved the sacred Lighthouse it's
already in the air and the Bromance can
be found paying their respects here the
rest of the POI looks to be airborne
before Halloween season hits next update
the cranes are here in full force the
tiny patches of chrome spotted two weeks
ago are now consumed this must be
unstoppable not even the foundation's
massive legs are safe The Columns Are
Climbing up his shins right now as no
sweat Insurance are playing a bigger
part in the story than ever before it's
only right to check on tilted Towers
next and even though the Chrome hasn't
reached here they've already ascended
away the building has gone in full up
mode and floated over to Kony which is
now named Chrome Crossroads some of this
place is lost while the most important
part the ice cream parlor is saved
another unexpected change can be found
in the sky The Flying Dutchman and the
Airship found at the Lagoon and Rave
cave are both on the Move somehow The
Galleon can now be found near Rocky
reels and its owner has no idea how it
happened and the recommissioned blimp is
almost over to a new POI Grim Gables I
guess we'll find out more about these
offensive Maneuvers in the upcoming
quest line we've already picked up the
origins planned in the bunkers could
this be part of his plan
one of the most random changes has
occurred at Shifty it's now Grim Gables
another Rift cracks the sky above and in
fell this new POI the mind is all but
closed down and a new rather spooky
house and cornfield are in its place the
owners either haven't moved in yet or
they never got to finish unpacking and
it isn't Halloween without a graveyard
and a pumpkin patch with the old loot
lake house here too next week's update
looks to be both massive for content and
linked to the storyline those who have
seen stranger things believe the
grandfather clock here is linked to that
show a crossover during Halloween is
imminent and here's me still on season
one and I have no idea what the clock
means yay my personal prediction for
Halloween is the return of the Marauders
do you remember those when they used to
crash down mid game those guys have
questions to answer and the poster kinda
looks like one of them
other pois that are now in the air
include the garage that sits all alone
it's in a few pieces but it's going
Skyward wood the opposite is happening
to the house to the north of this it's
been taken by the Chrome along with many
of the old IR Scout posts if like me
you've been keeping an eye on the teddy
in a bush since the chapter started it
looks very likely that he'll meet his
demise soon he didn't even get to do
anything the butter Barn is now the
flutter barn and this one escaped the
Chrome by moments the pillars are
building underneath and not all were
saved the van we used to keep cool in
summer yeah it's gone smaller pois have
been affected too the store by the farm
is now gone it's hexagon thank you very
much as the second tornado can now spawn
in game not even the reality tree is
safe it may be only a minor change but
more Columns of chrome grow here weekly
I still have no idea what the herald is
doing do you and an update I may need a
little help with a new minor POI has
been unveiled rickety rocks a modern
apartment overlooking the shore was
updated today but I don't seem to find
any changes here
my guess is that this has something to
do with a spooky update in two weeks oh
and this may not be a map change but I
think it's brilliant when throwing down
Potter bunkers they'll be covered in
your own emblems much easier to identify
who it belongs to by the way does anyone
else own the grenade icon I'm told it's
rare but I'm not sure
okay it's time for the real big news we
may have lost the rock family we may
have lost truckosaurus but the story of
the Bromance keeps on giving the duo
that found a friend this chapter in the
last reality's final trespasser who then
found a Lonely Island guard and invited
him along for the journey well those
four are officially a five now the seven
centuries venue was looking over to them
last update and now she's one of the
boys I'll be honest these sub stories
are the main reason to keep doing this
series millions of people couldn't care
less but you and I were different I did
plan to have a new name for the gang
this week but I got over 1 000
suggestions and I haven't gone through
them all yet my plan is to eventually
make a list of the top 20 and get you
guys to vote on it probably on Twitter
I'll be sure to link my Twitter in the
description if you want to vote on that
now there are five I thought we should
test something their ability to defend
each other and fight so I shot man cake
and then ran over for cover they may not
be the most galvanized of strike teams
but after a little watching they took
the fight to man cake and won with just
their pistols they kind of lost a member
on the way oh well in two weeks I'm
hoping these guys will get in the
Halloween spirits remember when the
Bromance had pumpkins for heads good
memories come on Epic do it again
surprisingly we have a lore update today
and it isn't one of the storyline
missions bite challenges have now
unlocked and they have revealed the
nothing to us a voice found inside a
television
we see you're finally prepared to face
your fate
But first you must prove yourself
since the season started we wondered
what the nothing is is it a person is it
a way of life and it seems to be an
entity and not literally nothing at all
hidden in the battle pass is bites who
is hounded by the nothing to become
their undercover agent Promises of gifts
keep him coming back for more the same
forces that will destroy the others will
raise you up the nothing has revealed
that bites is the first person in
lifetimes to progress this far in his
challenges and let's slip that the
nothing requires a warrior you are the
first in Generations
to survive this journey but there is
more to come
you are capable but we are seeking a
warrior will you continue bite now has a
taste of power and could soon be ready
to switch sides I mean I twitch sides
for a shiny right arms be a thing
wouldn't you I won't go too deep into
this right now let's give everyone time
to finish the challenges and once you've
done that please use the comments below
to share your theory on the nothing what
is it and what do they want bite may be
the real villain here inside our own
ranks after the Paradigm made contact
via new tree saplings any info about the
nothing is needed desperately the season
is finally hotting up I'm Adam you're
awesome I'll see you in a fortnight for
fortnite mess
[Music]
thank you
[Music]